hi everyone I'm Abbi
I'm the head TA for this class and I'm
also a PhD student in the sample NLP
group and today I'm gonna be telling you
about language models and recurrent
neural networks so here's an overview of
what we're going to do stay today first
we're going to introduce a new NLP task
that's language modeling and that's
going to motivate us to learn about a
new family of neural networks that is
recurrent neural networks or RN MS so
I'd say that these are two of the most
important ideas we're going to learn for
the rest of the course so we're going to
be covering some fairly core material
today so let's start off with language
modeling language modeling is the task
of predicting what words comes next
so given this piece of text the students
opened their blank could anyone shout
out a word which you think might be
coming next mine I didn't quite hear
them but yeah these are all likely
things right so these are some things
which I thought students might be
opening students open their books seems
likely students opened their laptops
students opened their exams students
open their minds incredibly someone came
up with on that one just now is kind of
a metaphorical meaning of opening so you
are all performing language modeling
right now in thinking about what word
comes next you are being a language
model so here's a more formal definition
of what a language model is given a
sequence of words x1 up to X T a
language model is something that
computes the probability distribution of
the next word xt plus1
so a language model comes up with the
probability distribution the conditional
probability of what xt plus one is given
the world so far and here we're assuming
that xt plus 1 can be any word w from a
fixed vocabulary v so we are assuming
that there's a predefined list of words
that we're considering in this way you
can view language modeling as a type of
classification task because there's a
predefined number of possibilities and
we call the system that does this a
language model there's an alternative
way of thinking about language model as
well you can think of a language model
as a system which assigns probability to
a piece of text
so for example if we have some piece of
text x1 up to X capital T then the
probability of this text according to
the language model can be broken down so
just by definition you can say that the
probability is equal to the product of
all of these conditional probabilities
and the form inside the product is
exactly what our language one of the
bytes so you can think of these things
as somewhat equivalent protecting the
next words gives you a system that can
give the probability of a given piece of
text so in fact you use language models
every day for example when you're
texting on your phone and you're writing
a message then most likely if you have a
smart phone it will be predicting what
word you might be about to say so if you
say I'll meet you at the your phone
might suggest how to me an airport or
cafe or office for example another
situation which use language models
everyday is when you search for
something on the internet for example
Google and you start typing your query
then Google tries to complete your query
for you and that's language modeling
it's predicting what word or words might
come next so that's what a language
model is and the question is how would
you learn a language model so if I was
to answer that question in the pre deep
learning era which was really only a few
years ago the answer would be you would
learn a 10-gram language model so today
first we're going to learn about Ngram
language models so before I can tell you
what an Engram language model is you
need to know what an Engram is so by
definition an Engram is a chunk of n
consecutive words so for example a 1
gram or unigram is just all of the
individual words in the sequence it
would be the students open their a to
graham or by graham would be all of the
section of trunks of pairs of words the
students students opened opened their
and so on for trigrams and for grams etc
so the core idea of an Engram language
model is that in order to predict what
word comes next you're going to collect
a bunch of statistics about how frequent
different engrams are from some kind of
training data and then you can use those
statistics to predict what next words
might be likely
here's more detail so to make an Engram
language model first need to make a
simplifying assumption and this is your
assumption you say that
next word xt plus1 depends only on the
preceding n minus-1 words so what we're
assuming is that the probability
distribution the conditional probability
of XT plus 1 given all of the words so
far we're just going to simplify that
and say it only depends on the last n
minus 1 words and that's our assumption
so by the definition of conditional
probability we can say that this
probability is just the ratio of two
different probabilities so on the top
you've got the probability of a
particular Engram and on the bottom
we've got the probability of a
particular n minus 1 gram this is a
little hard to read because of all the
superscripts but I'm going to give an
example with words on the next slide ok
so that's the definition of the
probability of the next word but the
question remains how do we get all of
these Engram and n minus 1 grand
probabilities so the answer is we're
going to get them by counting them in
some large corpus of text so we're going
to approximate these probabilities just
by the count of the number of times at
these particular n grams and n minus 1
grams appeared in our training corpus ok
so here's an example with some words
suppose we're trying to learn a 4 gram
language model and suppose that we have
a piece of text that says as the
proctors started the clock the students
opened their blank and we're trying to
predict what word is coming next so
because we're learning a foreground
language model our simplifying
assumption is that the next word depends
only on the last three words the last n
minus 1 words so we're going to discard
all of the contexts so far except for
the last 3 words which is students open
there so as a reminder our Engram
language model says that the probability
of the next word being some particular
word W in the vocabulary is equal to the
number of times we saw students open
their W divided by the number of times
we saw students open there in the
training corpus so let's suppose that in
our training corpus we saw the phrase
students opened their 1000 times and
suppose that we saw students open their
books 400 times this means that the
probability of the next one being books
is 0.4 and similarly let's suppose that
we saw students open their exams 100
times this means that the probability of
exams given students opened there in 0.1
is there a question
the question is does the order for voice
matter and the answer is yes the order
of students open there does matter it's
different to their students open so the
question I want to raise now is was it a
good idea for us to discard the proctor
context if you look at the actual
example that we had the example was as
the Proctor started the clock the
students open their blank so do we think
that books or exams is more likely given
the actual context the full context yep
exams right exams is more likely because
the proctor of the clock heavily implies
that its exam scenarios they're more
likely to be open exams than the books
unless it's an open book exam but I
think overall it should be exams so the
problem that we're seeing here is that
in the training corpus the fact that
students were opening something means
that it's more likely to be books and
exams because overall books and more
common in exams but if we know that the
context is the proctor and the clock
then it should be exams so what I'm
highlighting here is a problem with that
simplifying assumption if we throw away
too much context then we are not as good
as predicting the words as we would be
if we kept the context ok so that's one
problem with Engram language models
there are some other problems as well so
here again is the equation that you saw
before one problem which we're going to
call the sparsity problem is what
happens if the number on top the
numerator what if that count is equal to
0 so what if for some particular word w
the phrase students open there w never
occurred in the data so for example
let's suppose students open their petri
dishes is fairly uncommon and it never
appears in the data then that means that
our probability of the next word being
petri dishes will be 0 and this is bad
because it might be uncommon but it is a
valid scenario right if you're a biology
student for example so this is a problem
and we call it the sparsity problem
because the problem is that if we'd
never seen an event happen in the
training data then our model assigns
zero probability to that event so one
partial solution to this problem is that
maybe we should add a small Delta a
small number Delta to the count for
every word in the vocabulary and then
this way every possible word that come
next has at least some small probability
so
petri dishes will have some small
probability but then so will all of the
other words which are possibly bad
choices so this technique is called
smoothing because the idea is that
you're going from a very sparse
probability distribution which is zero
almost everywhere with a few spikes
where there's being engrams that we've
seen it goes from that to being a more
smooth probability distribution where
everything has at least a small
probability on
so the second sparsity problem which is
possibly worse than the first one is
what happens if the number in the
denominator is zero so in our example
that would mean what if we never even
saw the trigram students open there in
the training data
if that happened then we can't even
calculate this probability distribution
at all for any word W because we never
even saw this context before so a
possible solution for this is that if
you can't find students open there in
the corpus then you should back off -
just conditioning on the last two words
rather than the last three words so now
you would be looking at times when you'd
seen open there and seeing what words
come next so this is called back off
because in this failure case for when
you have no data if you're for Gram
language model you're backing off to a
trigram language model there any
questions at this point
okay so another thing to note is that
these sparsity problems get worse if you
increase n if you make n larger in your
Engram language model and you might want
to do this for example you might think I
want to have a larger context so that I
can pay attention to was that happen
longer ago and that's going to make it a
better predictor so you might think
making n bigger is a good idea but the
problem is if you do that then these
sparsity problems get worse because
let's suppose you say I want a 10-gram
language model then the problem is that
you're going to be counting how often
you see input certain 9 grams and 10
grams but 9 grams and 10 grams that so
many of them that the one you're
interested in probably never occurred in
your training data which means that the
whole thing becomes dysfunctional so in
practice we usually can't have n much
bigger than 5 okay so that was 2
sparsity problems with Engram language
models here's a problem with storage so
if we look at this equation you have to
think about what do you need to store in
order to use your Engram language model
you need to store this count number for
all of the engrams that you observed in
the corpus when you were going to the
training corpus counting them and the
problem is that as you increase n then
this number of engrams that you have to
store and count increases so another
problem with increasing n is that the
size of your model of your Engram model
gets bigger
okay so Engram language models in
practice let's look an example you can
actually build a simple trigram language
model over a 1.7 million word corpus in
a few seconds on your laptop and in fact
the corporate relay used to do this was
the same one that you met in assignment
1 its Reuters corpus which is business
and financial news so if you want to do
this for yourself you can follow that
link at the bottom of the slide later so
this is something which I ran on my
laptop in a few seconds so I gave it the
context of the bigram
today the and then I asked the trigram
language model what word is likely to
come next so the language model said
that the top next most likely words are
company Bank price Italian Emirates etc
so already just looking at these
probabilities that assigned to these
different words you can see that there's
a sparsity problem for example the top
two most likely words have the exact
same probability and the reason for that
is that this number is
for over 26 so these are all quite small
integers meaning that we only saw today
the company and today the bank four
times each so this is an example of the
sparsity problem because overall these
are quite low counts we haven't seen
that many different versions of this
event so we don't have a very granular
probability distribution but in any case
ignoring the sparsity problem I would
say that overall these top suggestions
look pretty reasonable so you can
actually use a language model to
generate text and this is how you would
do it so let's suppose you have your
first two words already you conditional
this and you ask your language model
what's likely to come next so then given
this probability distribution over the
words you can sample from it that is
select some words with you know the
Associated probability so let's suppose
that gives us the word price so then
price is your next words and then you
just condition on the last two words
which in this example is now the price
so now you gets new probability
distribution and you can continue this
process sampling and then conditioning
again and something so if you do this
long enough you will get a piece of text
so this is the actual text that I got
when I ran this generation process with
this trigram language model so it says
today the price of gold per ton while
production of shoe lasts and shoe
industry the bank intervened just after
it considered and rejected and IMF
demands to rebuild depleted european
stocks September 30th and primary 76
counts a share okay so what do we think
about this text we think it's good are
we surprised I would say that in some
ways it is good it's kind of
surprisingly grammatical you know it
mostly kind of pauses but you would
definitely say that it doesn't really
make any sense it's pretty incoherent
and we shouldn't be surprised at this
incoherent I think because if you
remember this is a trigram language
model it has a memory of just the last
well 3 or 2 words depending on how you
look at it so clearly we need to
consider more than three words at a time
if we want to model language well but as
we already know increasing n makes the
sparsity problem worse and grande
language models and it also increases
the model size is that a question
so the question is how does the anger
and language model know when to put
commas so you can decide that commas and
other punctuation are just another kind
of word as well or token and then to the
language model it doesn't really make
much difference it just means that as
another possible word that could be
predicted that's why we've got the weird
spacing around the Commons it's because
it was essentially viewed as a separate
word okay so this course is called NLP
with deep learning so you're probably
thinking how do we build a neural
language model so let's just recap in
case you forgot remember that a language
model is something that takes inputs
which is a sequence of words X 1 up to X
T and then it outputs a probability
distribution of what the next word might
be XT plus 1 ok so when we think about
what kind of newer models we met in this
car so far we've already met window
based neuron models and in lecture 3 we
saw how you could apply a window based
neural model to named entity recognition
so in that scenario you take some kind
of window around the word that you care
about which in this example is Paris and
then you get the word embeddings for
those concatenate them put them through
some layers and then you get your
decision which is that Paris is of
location not you know a person or
organization so that's a recap of what
we saw in lecture 3 how would we apply a
model like this to language modeling so
here's how you doing here's an example
of a fixed window neuron language model
so again we have some kind of context
which is as the Procter started the
clock the students open there and we're
trying to guess what words might come
next so we have to make a similar
simplifying assumption to before because
it's a fixed sized window we have to
discard the context except for the
window that we're conditioning on
so that's suppose that our fixed window
is of size 4 so what we'll do is
similarly to the NE our model we're
going to represent these words with
one-hot vectors and then we'll use those
to look up the word embeddings so for
these words using the embedding lookup
matrix so then we get all of our wedding
beddings ie 1 2 3 4 and then we can
calculate them together to get e we put
this through a linear layer and
nonlinearity function f to get some kind
of hidden layer and then we put this
through another linear layer and the
softmax function and now we have an
output probability distribution Y hat
and in our case because we're trying to
predict what word comes next our vector
Y hats will be of length V where V is
the vocabulary and it will contain the
probabilities of all the different words
in the vocabulary so here I've
represented that as a bar chart where if
you suppose you've got all of the words
that sit alphabetically from A to zoo
and then there's the different
probabilities of the words so if
everything goes well then this language
model should tell us that some likely
next words are books and laptops for
example so none of this should be
unfamiliar to you because he saw us all
last week we're just applying a window
based model to a different task such as
language modeling ok so what are some
good things about this model compared to
Engram language models so one advantage
I'd say is that there's no sparsity
problem if you remember an Engram
language model has a sparsity problem
which is that if you've never seen a
particular Engram in training then you
can't assign any probability to it you
don't have any data on it whereas at
least here you can take any you know for
example for gramm you want and you can
feed it into the neural nets and it will
give you an output distribution of what
it thinks the next word would be it
might not be a good prediction but at
least it will kill will run another
advantage is you don't need to store all
of the observed engrams that you ever
saw so this an advantage by comparison
you just have to store all of the word
vectors for all the words in your
vocabulary but there are quite a lot of
problems with this fixed window language
model so here are some remaining
problems one is that your fixed window
is probably too small no matter how big
you make your fixed window you're
probably going to be losing some kind of
useful context that you would want to
use sometimes and in fact if you try to
enlarge the window size then you also
have to enlarge the size of your weight
vector so your weight matrix W so the
width of W because you're multiplying it
by E which is the concatenation of your
word embeddings the width of W grows as
you increase the size of your window so
in conclusion really your window can
never be large enough another problem
with this model which is more of a
subtle point is that XY
next to and really all of the words in
the window they're multiplied by
completely different weights in W so to
demonstrate this you could draw a
picture so the problem is that if you
have your weight matrix W and then you
have your caffeination of embeddings e
and we have for embedding so we have e1
e2 e3 e4 and you multiply the
concatenate embeddings by the weight
matrix so really you can see that there
are essentially kind of four sections of
the weight matrix and the first word
embedding a1 is only ever multiplied by
the weights that are in this section and
that's completely separate to the
weights that multiply e2 and so forth so
the problem with this is that what you
learn in the weight matrix in one
section is not shared with the others
you're kind of learning a lot of similar
functions for x so the reason why we
think this is a problem is because there
should be a lot of commonalities in how
you process the incoming Werner
belling's so what you learn about how to
process you know the third embedding
some of it at least should be shared
with all of the embeddings so what I'm
saying is it's kind of inefficient that
we're learning all of these separate
weights for these different words when
there's a lot of commonalities between
them is their question yeah hopefully
hopefully they're verbal description so
in confusion I'd say that the biggest
problem that we've got with this fixed
size neural model is that clearly we
need some kind of neural architecture
that can process any length input
because most of the problems here come
from the fact that we had to make this
simplifying assumption that there was a
fixed window ok so this motivates us to
introduce this new family of neural
architecture it's called recurrent
neural networks or RNs so this is a
simplified diagram that shows you the
most important features of an RNN so we
have again an input sequence of X 1 X 2
etc but you can assume that this
sequence is of any arbitrary lengths you
like
the idea is that you have a sequence of
hidden states instead of just having for
example one hidden state as we did in
the previous model we have a sequence of
hidden States and we have as many of
them as we have inputs and the important
thing is that each hidden state HT is
computed based on the previous hidden
state and also the input on that step so
the reason why they're called hidden
States is because you could think of
this as a single state that's mutating
over time it's kind of like several
versions of the same thing and for this
reason we often call these time steps
right so these steps that go left to
right we often call them time steps so
the really important thing is that the
same weight matrix W is applied on every
time step of this RNN that's what makes
us able to process any length input we
want is because we don't have to have
different weights on every step because
we just apply the exact same
transformation on every step so
additionally you can also have some
outputs from the RNA so these Y hats
these are the outputs on each step and
they're optional because you don't have
to compute them or you can compute them
on just some steps and not others it
depends on what you want to use your RNN
to do okay so that's a simple diagram of
an RNN here I'm going to give you a bit
more details so here's how you would
apply an RNN to do language modeling so
again let's suppose that we have some
kind of text so far my text is only four
words long but you can assume that it
could be any lengths right it's just
short because we can't fit more on the
slide so you have some sequence of text
which could be kind of long and again
we're going to represent these via some
kind of one hunters and use those to
look up the word embeddings from our
embedding matrix so then to compute the
first hidden state h1 we need to compute
it based on the previous hidden state
and the current input we already have
the current input that's a 1 but the
question is where do we get this first
hidden state from right what comes
before h1 so we often call the initial
hidden state h0 yeah we call the initial
hidden state and it can either be
something that you learn like it's a
parameter of the network and you learn
how to initialize it or you can assume
something
like maybe it's the zero vector so the
the formula we use to compute the new
hidden state based on the previous one
and also the current input is written on
the left so you do a linear
transformation on the previous hidden
state and on the current inputs and then
you add some kind of bias and then put
it through a non-linearity like for
example the sigmoid function and that
gives you a new hidden state okay so
once you've done that then you can
compute the next hidden States and you
can keep unrolling the network like this
and that's yeah that's called unrolling
because you're kind of computing each
step given the previous one all right so
finally if you remember we're trying to
do language modeling so we're trying to
predict which word should come next
after the students open there so on this
fourth step over here we can use the
current hidden state h4 and put it
through a linear layer and put it
through a softmax function and then we
get our output distribution Y hat four
which is a distribution over the
vocabulary and again hopefully we'll get
some kind of sensible estimates for what
the next word might be any questions at
this point yep 18 states oh it's going
to be the number of words yeah in this
setting here yes or you could say more
generally the number of hidden states is
the number of inputs yep so the question
is as with the engram language model
could be used the output is the input on
the next step and the answer is yes I'll
show you that in a minute
any other questions
embeddings the question is are you
learning the embeddings that's a choice
you could have the embeddings be for
example pre-trained embeddings that you
download and you use those and they're
frozen or maybe you could download them
but then you could fine tune them that
is allow them to be changed as
parameters of the network or you could
initialize them to you know small random
values and learn them from scratch
any other questions yes so you certainly
use the same matrix what if you like
back propagation does that mean the only
update way W users we are they both W so
the question is you say we reused the
matrix to be update W and WH or just one
so you suddenly learn both W e and WH I
suppose I was emphasizing WH more but
yeah they're both matrices that are
applied repeatedly there was also a
question about back prop but we're going
to cover that later in this lecture okay
moving on for now so what are some
advantages and disadvantages of this R
and M language model so here are some
advantages that we can see in comparison
to the fixed window one so an obvious
advantage is that this RN n can process
any length of input another advantage is
that the computation for step T can in
theory use information from many steps
back
so in our motivating example which was
as the proctor started the clock the
students open there we think that
Proctor and maybe clock are both pretty
important hints for what might be coming
up next so at least in theory the hidden
states at the end can have access to the
information from the input from many
steps ago another advantage is that the
model size doesn't increase for longer
input so the size of the model is
actually fixed it's just WH and W e and
then also the bias ease and also the
embedding matrix if you're counting that
and none of those get bigger if you want
to apply it to more longer inputs
because you just apply the same weights
repeatedly and another advantage is that
you have the same weights applied on
every time step so I said this thing
before about how the fixed sized window
neural model it was less efficient
because it was applying different
weights of the weight matrix to the
difference words in the window and the
advantage about this RNN is that it's
applying the exact same transformation
to each of the inputs so this means that
if it learns a good way to process one
input that is applied to every input in
the sequence so you can see it as more
efficient in that way okay so what are
the disadvantages of this model
one is that recurrent computation is
pretty slow as you saw before you have
to compute the hidden state based on the
previous hidden states so this means
that you can't compute all the hidden
States in parallel you have to compute
them in sequence so especially if you're
trying to compute an RNN over a pretty
long sequence of inputs this means that
the RNN can be pretty slow to compute
another disadvantage difference is that
it turns out in practice it's quite
difficult to access information from
many steps back so even though I said we
should be able to remember about the
Proctor and the clock and use that to
predict exams not books it turns out
that are and ends at least the ones that
I've presented in this lecture are not
as good as that as you would think and
we're going to learn more about both of
these disadvantages later in the course
and we're going to learn something about
how you can try to fix them have we got
any proper any questions at this point
yep
so the question is why should you assume
that the wh are the same I suppose is
not exactly an assumption that's more a
deliberate decision in the design of an
RNN so an RNN is by definition a network
where you apply the exact same weights
on every step so I suppose the question
why do you assume maybe should be why is
that a good idea
so I spoke a little bit about why it's a
good idea and this advantages I suppose
are the reasons why you would want to do
that approximation okay this is just
approximation transfer you shouldn't be
saying okay special and so I think the
question is saying that given that these
words the students open there are all
different and they're happening in
different contexts then why should we be
applying the same transformation each
time so that's a that's a good question
I think the idea is that you are
learning a general function not just you
know how to deal with students the one
word students in this one context we're
trying to learn a general function of
how you should deal with a word given
the word so far you're trying to learn a
general representation of language in
context so far which is indeed a very
difficult problem I think you also
mentioned that something about an
approximation another thing to note is
that all of the hidden states are
vectors not just single numbers right
there vectors of Thanks I don't know 500
or something so they have quite a large
capacity to hold a lot of in from
about different things in all of their
different positions so I think the idea
is that you can store a lot of different
information in different contexts in
different parts of the hidden state but
it is indeed an approximation and there
is some kind of limits how much
information you can store okay any other
questions yep since it cannot process
any single day right what do you use for
your training and that's the knife you
use for training okay so the question is
given that you can have any length
inputs what length is the input during
training so I suppose in practice you
choose how long the inputs are in
training either based on what your data
is or maybe based on your efficiency
concerns so maybe you make it
artificially shorter by chopping it up
what was the other question the story
should apparently okay so the question
was does WH depend on the length used so
no and that's one of the good things in
the advantages list is that the model
size doesn't increase for longer inputs
because we just unroll the RNN applying
the same weights again again for as long
as we like there's no need to have more
weights just because you have a longer
input are you asking about capsule e or
the lower cases okay so the question is
how do we choose the dimension of the
lower case ease so you could for example
assume that those are just pre trained
word vectors like the ones that you used
in assignment one yeah for example words
back and you just download them and use
them or maybe you learn the from scratch
in which case you decide at the
beginning of training how big you want
this back just to be okay I'm gonna move
on for now
so we've learnt water are in a language
model is and we've learned how you would
run one for words but the question
remains how would you train an RNN
language model how would you learn it so
as always the machine learning our
answer starts with you're going to get a
big corpus of text and we're going to
call that just a sequence of words X 1
up to X capital T so you feed the
sequence of words into the RNN language
model and then the idea is that you
compute the output distribution Y hat T
for every step T so I know that the
picture I showed on the previous slide
only showed us two
on the last step but the idea is you
would actually compute this on every
step so this means that you're actually
predicting the probability of the next
word on every step okay so once you've
done that then you can define the loss
function and this should be familiar to
you by now
this is the cross entropy between our
predicted probability distribution Y hat
T and the true distribution which is y
hat sorry just YT which is a one hot
vector representing the true next words
which is XT plus 1 so as you've seen
before this cross entropy between those
two vectors can be written also as a
negative log probability and then lastly
if you average this cross entropy loss
across every step every T in the corpus
time step T then this gives you your
overall loss for the entire training set
ok so just to make that even more clear
with a picture suppose that our corpus
is that the students open their exams
etc and it goes on for a long time then
what we'd be doing is we'd be running
our R and n over this text and then on
every step we would be predicting the
probability distribution Y hats and then
from each of those you can calculate
what your losses which is the JT and
then on the first step the loss would be
the negative log probability of the next
words which is in this example students
and so on each of those is the negative
log probability of the next word and
then once you compute all of those you
can add them all up and average them and
then this gives you your final loss ok
so there's a caveat here computing the
loss ingredients across the entire
corpus all of those words x1 up to X
capital T is too expensive because your
corpus is probably really big so as a
student asked earlier in practice what
do you actually regard as a sequence so
in practice you might regard your
sequence is something like a sentence or
a document some shorter unit of text so
another thing you will do is if you
remember stochastic gradient descents
allows you to compute gradients for
small chunks of data rather than the
whole corpus at a time so in practice if
you're training a language model while
you're actually likely to be doing is
computing the loss for a sentence but
that's actually a batch of sentences and
then you compute the gradients with
respect
about your sentences update your weights
and repeat any questions at this point
okay so moving on to backdrop don't
worry there won't be as much backdrop as
there was last week but there is an
interesting question here right so the
characteristic thing about rnns is that
they apply the same weight matrix
repeatedly so the question is what's the
derivative of our loss function let's
say on step T what's the derivative of
that loss with respect to the repeated
weigh matrix WH so the answer is that
the derivative of the loss the gradient
with respect to the repeated weight is
the sum of the gradient with respect to
each time it appears and that's what
that equation says so on the right the
notation with a vertical line in the eye
is saying the derivative of the loss
with respect to WH when it appears on
the ISTEP okay so so why is that true to
sketch why this is true I'm gonna remind
you of the multivariable chain rule so
this is a screenshot from a Khan Academy
article on the multivariable chain rule
and I advise you to check it out if you
want to learn more because it's very
easy to understand and what it says is
given a function f which depends on x
and y which are both themselves
functions of some variable T then if you
want to get the derivative of F with
respect to T then you need to do the
chain rule across x and y separately and
then add them up so that's the
multivariable chain rule and if we apply
this to our scenario with trying to take
the derivative of the last JT with
respect to our weight matrix WH then you
can view it as this kind of diagram
where WH has a relationship with all of
these individual appearances of WH but
it's a simple relationship it's just
equality and then each of those
appearances of WH affect the loss in
different ways so then if we apply the
multivariable chain rule then it says
that the derivative of the loss with
respect to WH is the sum of those chain
rule things but the expression on the
right is just one because it's an
equality relation and then that gives us
the equation that I wrote on the
previous slide
so this is a proof sketch for why the
derivative of the last with respect to
our recurrent matrix is the sum of the
derivatives each time it appears okay so
suppose you believe me on that that is
how you compute the gradient with
respect to the recurrent wave
so a remaining question is well how do
we actually calculate this in practice
so the answer is that you're going to
calculate this sum by doing back prop
backwards kind of right to left through
the RNN and you're going to accumulate
this sum as you go so the important
thing is you shouldn't compute each of
those things separately you should
compute them by accumulating like each
one can be computed in form in terms of
the previous one so this algorithm of
computing each of these each of these
gradients with respect to the previous
one is called back propagation through
time and I always think that this sounds
way more sci-fi than it is it sounds
like it's time travel or something but
it's actually pretty simple it's just
the name you give to applying the back
prop algorithm to a recurrent neural
network any questions at this point yep
QG impacts because like you only update
the next pair after you back to the time
of the first batch so if you break into
much more irregular badges okay so the
question is surely how you decide to
break up your batches affects how you
learn right because if you choose one
set of data to be your batch right then
you will make your update based on that
and then you only update the next one
based on where you got from there so if
you decided to put different data in the
batch then you would have made a
different step so that's true and that
is why stochastic gradient descent is
only an approximation of true gradient
descent because the gradient that you
compute with respect to one batch is
just an approximation of the true
gradient with respect to the the loss
over the whole corpus so yes it's true
that in this approximation and how you
choose to patch up your data can matter
and that's why for example shuffling
your data is a good idea and shuffling
it differently each epoch is a
good idea but the the core idea of SPD
is that it should be a good enough
approximation that over many steps you
will minimize yours any other questions
so is is the question as you compute
forward prop do you start computing back
prop before you even like got to the
loss is that the question yes I don't
think so right because you need to know
what the loss is in order to compute the
derivative of the last with respect to
something so I think you need to get to
the end so if we assume for simplicity
that there is only one loss which you
get at the end of several steps then you
need to get to the end P P the loss
before you can compute the derivatives
but I suppose you could compute the
derivative of two kind of adjacent
things of one with respect to the other
yes so when you keep or drop you
certainly have to hang on to one of the
answer okay I'm gonna move on for now so
that was a maths heavy bit but now we're
getting on to text generation which
someone asked about earlier so just as
we use the Engram language models to
generate text you can also use an RNN
language model to generate text via the
same repeated sampling technique so
here's a picture of how that would work
you start off with your initial hidden
state h0 which we have either as a
parameter of the model we initialize it
to zero or something like that
so let's suppose that we have the first
word my and i suppose i supply that to
the model so then using the input and
the initial hidden state you can get our
first state h1 and then from there we
can compute the probability distribution
Y hat one of what's coming next and then
we can use that distribution to sample
some word so that's supposed to be
sample the word favorite so the idea is
that we use the outputted words as the
inputs on the next step so we feed
favorite into the second step of the RNN
we get a new hidden States
and again we get a new probability
distribution and from that we can sample
a new word so we can just continue doing
this processes again again and in this
way we can generate some text so here
we've generated the text my favorite
season is spring and we can keep going
for as long as long as we like okay so
let's have some fun with this you can
generate text using an RNN language
model if you train the RNN language
model on any kind of text then you can
use it to generate text in that style
and in fact this has become a whole kind
of genre of internet humor you might
have seen so for example here is an RNN
language model trained on obama speeches
and I found this in a blog post online
so here's a text that the RNN language
model generated the United States will
step up to the cost of a new challenges
of the American people that will share
the fact that we created the problem
they were attacked and so that they have
to say that all the tasks of the final
days of war that I will not be able to
get this done ok so if we look at this
and especially think about what did that
text look like that we got from the
Ngram language model the one about the
the price of goals I'd say that this is
kind of recognizably better than that it
seems more fluent overall I'd say it has
a more of a sustained context in that it
kind of makes sense for longer stretches
at a time and I'd say it does sound
tonally like a bomber as well so
although that's pretty good
but you can see that it's still pretty
incoherent overall like it was quite
difficult to read it because it didn't
really make sense right so I had to read
the words carefully so yeah I think this
shows some of the progress you can get
from using our intends to generate text
but still very far from human level here
are some more examples here's an R in an
Irish model that was trained on the
Harry Potter books and here's what I
said sorry Harry shouted panicking I'll
leave those brooms in London are they no
idea said nearly headless Nick casting
low close by Cedric carrying the last
bit of treacle charms from Harry's
shoulder and to answer him the common
room perched upon it forearms held a
shining knob from when the spider
felt it seemed he reached the teams too
so again I'd say that this is fairly
fluent it sounds totally like the Harry
Potter books in fact I'm pretty
impressed by how much it does sound like
in the voice of the Harry Potter books
you even got some character attributes
I'd say that Harry the character does
often panic in the book so that seems
right but some bad things are that we
have for example a pretty long run-on
sentence in the second paragraph that's
hard to read you have some nonsensical
things that really make no sense like I
don't know what a treacle trama it
sounds delicious but I don't think it's
real and overall it's just pretty
nonsensical here's another example here
is an iron in language model that was
trained on recipes so uh this one's
pretty bizarre the title is chocolate
ranch barbeque it contains Parmesan
cheese coconut milk eggs and the recipe
says placed each pasta over layers of
lumps shape mixture into the moderates
oven and simmer until firm serve hot
embodied fresh mustard orange and cheese
combine the cheese and salt together the
dough in a large skillet add the
ingredients and stir in the chocolate
and pepper so one thing that I think is
even more clear here in the recipes
example than the pros example is the
inability to remember what's what's
happening overall right because a recipe
you could say is pretty challenging
because you need to remember the title
of what you're trying to make which in
this case is chocolate ranch barbecue
and you need to actually you know make
that thing by the end you also need to
remember what we can greet in the
beginning and did you use them and in a
recipe if you make something and put it
in the oven you need to take it out
later
and stuff like that right so clearly
it's not really remembering what's
happening overall or what it's trying to
do it seems to be just generating kind
of generic recipe sentences and putting
them in a random order but again I mean
we can see that it's fairly fluent it's
grammatically right it kind of sounds
like a recipe but the problem is there's
just nonsense cool like for example
shape mixture into the moderate oven is
grammatical but it doesn't make any
sense
okay last example so here is an errand
and language model that's trained on
paints color names and this is an
example of a character level language
model because it's predicting what
character comes next
not what word comes next and this is why
it's Abe
to come up with new words another thing
to note is that this language model was
trained to be conditioned on some kind
of input so here the input is the color
itself I think represented by the three
numbers that's probably RGB numbers and
it generated some names for the colors
and I think these are pretty funny my
favorite one is stanky bean which is in
the bottom right so it's pretty creative
and I think these do sound kind of like
paint colors but often they're quite
bizarre light of blast is pretty good
too so you're going to learn more about
character level language models in a
future lecture and you're also going to
learn more about how to condition a
language model based on some kind of
input such as the color code so these
are pretty funny but I do want to say a
warning you'll find a lot of these kinds
of articles online often with headlines
like we forced a bot to watch you know
1,000 hours of sci-fi movies and it rose
scripts something like that so my advice
is you have to take these with a big
pinch of salt because often the examples
that people put online were hand
selected by humans to be the funniest
examples like I think all of the
examples I've shown today we're
definitely hand selected by humans as
the funniest examples that the RNN came
up with and in some cases they might
even have been edited by a human
so yeah you do need to be a little bit
skeptical when you look at these
examples yep so do you expect Aaron like
when inputs are opening quote and keeps
putting forward do you expect the
probability of a closing quote so that
increase as you're going forward that's
a great question so the question was we
noticed that in the Harry Potter example
there were some open quotes and some
closed quotes and it looks like the
model didn't screw up right all of these
open quotes and close quotes are in the
correct places so the question is do we
expect the model to put a higher
probability on closing the quote given
that it's inside a quote passage so I
should say definitely yes and that's
mostly the explanation for why this
worked there's been some really
interesting work in trying to look
inside the hidden states of language
models to
whether it's tracking things like are we
inside an open quote or a close quote
and there has been some limited evidence
to show that maybe there are certain
neuron or neurons inside the hidden
state which are tracking things like are
we currently inside a quote or not
increasing more question is as the
quoted passage goes on for longer do you
think the priority or the probability of
outputting a close quote should increase
I don't know maybe that would be good I
suppose because you don't want an
infinite quote but I wouldn't be
surprised if that didn't happen like I
wouldn't be surprised if maybe some
other worst trained language models just
open quotes and never close them any
other questions yep okay so the question
is what are the dimensions of the W
matrices so we're going back to the RN
and stuff okay you asking about WH or
w/e or something else so WH will be if
we say that the hidden size has size n
then WH will be n by n and if we suppose
that the embeddings have size d then w e
will be d by and n by d maybe designed
to a question any other questions about
generation or intelligence yep so you
said that those are long sentences
practically the combiner ends with my
conditions sorry is ever practical
combined or an ends with the richness of
handwritten rules okay yeah that's a
great question so the question was is it
ever practical to combine RN ends with a
list of handwritten rules for example
don't let your sentence be longer than
this many words so yeah I'd say it
probably is practical maybe especially
if you're interested in making sure that
certain bad things don't happen you
might apply some hockey rules like yeah
forcing it and early I mean okay so
there's this thing called beam search
which we're going to learn about in a
later lecture which essentially doesn't
just choose one word and each step and
continue it explores many different
options for what you could generate and
you can apply some kinds of
rules on that where if you have lots of
different things to choose from then you
can maybe get rid of some options if you
don't like them because they break some
of your rules but it can be difficult to
do any other questions okay so we've
talked about generating from language
models so unfortunately you can't just
use generation as your evaluation metric
for language models you do need some
kind of measurable metric so the
standard evaluation metric for language
models is called perplexity and
perplexity is defined as the inverse
probability of the corpus according to
the language model so if you look at it
you can see that that's what this
formula is saying it's saying that for
every words XT low-caste in the corpus
we're computing the probability of that
word given everything that came so far
but it's inverse so it's 1 over that and
then lastly we're normalizing this big
products by the number of words which is
capital T and the reason why we're doing
that is because if we didn't do that
then perplexity would just get smaller
and smaller as your corpus got bigger so
we need to normalize by that factor so
you can actually show that this affects
T is equal to the exponential of the
cross entropy loss J Sita so if you
remember cross-entropy loss J's isa
is the training objective that we're
using to train the language model and by
rearranging things a little bit you can
see that perplexity is actually the
exponential of the cross entropy and
this is a good thing because if we're
training the language model to minimize
the cross entropy loss then you are
training it to optimize the effects C as
well so you should remember that the
lower of Alexa T is better because
Perplexus C is the inverse probability
of the corpus so if you want your
language model to assign high
probability to the corpus right then
that means you want to get low products
T any questions
okay so our lands have been pretty
successful in recent years in improving
perplexity so this is a results table
from a recent Facebook research paper
about RNN language models and you don't
have to understand all of the details of
this table but what it's telling you is
that on the top row we have an Engram
language model and then in the
subsequent rows we have some
increasingly complex and large RN ends
and you can see that the perplexity
numbers are decreasing because lower is
better so ions have been really great
for making more effective language
models in the last few years okay so to
zoom out a little bit you might be
thinking oh why should I care about
language modeling why is it important
I'd say there are two main reasons why
language modeling is important so the
first one is that language modeling is a
benchmark task that helps us measure our
progress on understanding language so
you could view language modeling as a
pretty general language understanding
tasks right because predicting what word
comes next
given any any kind of generic text
that's quite a difficult and general
problem and in order to be good at
language modeling you have to understand
a lot of things right you have to
understand grammar you have to
understand syntax and you have to
understand logic and reasoning and you
have to understand something about you
know real world knowledge you have to
understand a lot of things in order to
be able to do language modeling properly
so the reason why we care about it is a
benchmark task is because if you're able
to build a model which is a better
language model than the ones that came
before it then you must have made some
kind of progress on at least some of
those sub components of natural language
understanding so another more tangible
reason why you might care about language
modeling is that it's a sub component of
many many NLP tasks especially those
which involve generating text or
estimating the probability of text
so here's a bunch of examples one is
predictive typing that's the example
that we showed at the beginning of the
lecture with typing on your phone or
searching on Google this is also very
useful for people who have movement
disabilities because there are these
systems that help people communicate
using fewer movements
another example is speech recognition so
in speech recognition you have some kind
of audio recording of a person saying
something and often it's kind of noisy
and hard to make out what they're saying
and you need to figure out what words
did they say so this is an example where
you have to estimate the probability of
different different options of what it
is they could have said and in the same
way handwriting recognition is an
example where there's a lot of noise and
you have to figure out what the person
intended to say spelling and grammar
correction is yet another example where
it's all about trying to figure out what
someone meant and that means you
actually understand how likely it is
that they were saying different things
an interesting an interesting
application is authorship identification
so suppose that you have a piece of text
and you're trying to figure out who
likely wrote it and maybe you have
several different authors and you have
text written by those different authors
so you could for example train a
separate language model on each of the
different authors texts and then because
you remember a language model can tell
you the probability of a given piece of
text then you could ask all the
different language models how likely the
the text on the question is and then if
a certain author's language model says
that it's likely then that means that
text the text on the question is more
likely to be written by that author
other examples include machine
translation this is a huge application
of language models because it's all
about generating text similarly
summarization is a task where you need
to generate some texts given some input
text dialog as well not all dialogue
agents necessarily RNN language models
but you can build a dialogue agent that
generates the text using an RNN language
model and there are more examples as
well any questions on this yep
vision or speech recognition there are
other input sources such as images or
audio clouds great question so the
question was for some of these examples
such as speech recognition or maybe
image captioning the input is audio or
image or something that is not text
right so you can't represent it in the
way that we've talked about so far so in
those examples you will have some way of
representing the input some way of
encoding the audio or the image or
whatever the reason I brought it up now
in terms of language models is that
that's the inputs but you use the
language model to get the output right
so the language model generates the
output in the way that we saw earlier
but we're gonna learn more about those
conditional language models later anyone
else okay so here's a recap if I've lost
you somewhere in this lecture or you got
tired now is a great time to jump back
in because things going to get a little
bit more accessible okay so here's a
recap of what we've done today a
language model is a system that predicts
the next word and the recurrent neural
network is a new family or new to us a
family of neural networks that takes
sequential input of any length and it
applies the same weights on every step
and it can optionally produce some kind
of output on each step or some of the
steps or none of the steps so don't be
confused a recurrent neural network is
not the same thing as a language model
we've seen today that an RN ends is a
great way to build a language model but
actually it turns out you can use RN
ends for a lot of other different things
that are not language modeling so here's
a few examples of that you can use an
RNN to do a tagging task so some
examples of tagging tasks are part of
speech tagging and named entity
recognition so pictured here is part of
speech tagging and this is the task
where you have some kind of input text
such as the startled cat knocked over
the VARs and your job is to label or tag
each word with its parts of speech so
for example cats a noun and knocked is a
verb so you can use an RNN to do this
task in
in the way that we've pictures which is
that you feed the text into the RNN and
then on each step of the RNN you have an
output probably a distribution over what
tag you think it is and then you can tag
it in that way and then also for named
entity recognition that's all about
tagging each of the words with what a
named entity type they are so you do it
in the same way okay here's another
thing you can use our announce for you
can use them for sentence classification
so sentence classification is just a
general term to mean any kind of task
where you want to take a sentence or
other piece of text and then you want to
classify it into one of several classes
so an example of that is sentiment
classification sentiment classification
is when you have some kind of input text
such as let's say overall I enjoyed the
movie a lot and then you're trying to
classify that as being positive or
negative or neutral sentiment so in this
example this is positive sentiment so
one way you might use an RNN to tackle
this task is you might encode the text
using the RNN and then really what you
want is some kind of sentence encoding
so that you can output your label for
the sentence right and it would be
useful she'd have a single vector to
represent the sentence rather than all
of these separate vectors so how would
you do this how would you get the
sentence encoding from the RNN one thing
you could do is you could use the final
hidden state as your sentence encoding
so the reason why you might think this
is a good idea is because for example in
the RNN we regard the the final hidden
state as this is a thing you use to
predict what's coming next right so
we're assuming that the final hidden
state contains information about all of
the text that this come so far right so
for that reason you might suppose that
this is a good sentence encoding and we
could use that to predict you know what
what sentiment is their sentence turns
out that usually a better way to do this
usually a more effective way is to do
something like maybe take an
element-wise max or an element-wise mean
of all these hidden states to get your
sentence encoding and this tends to work
better than just using the final hidden
state there are some other more advanced
things you can do as well
okay another thing that you can use iron
tents for is as a general purpose
encoder module so here's an example
that's question-answering but really
this idea of RN ends as a general
purpose encoder module is very common
and use it in a lot of different deep
learning architectures for NRP so here's
an example which is question-answering
so let's suppose that the the task is
you've got some kind of context switch
in this situation is the Wikipedia
article on Beethoven and then you have a
question which is asking what
nationality was Beethoven and this is
actually taken from the squads challenge
which is the subject of the default
final project so if you choose to do to
do the default final project you're
going to be building systems that solve
this problem so what you might do is you
might use an RNN to process the question
what nationality was Beethoven and then
you might use those hidden States that
you get from this RNA of the question as
a representation of the question and I'm
being intentionally vague here about
what might happen next but the idea is
that you have both the context and the
question are going to be fed some way
and maybe you're using rnm on context as
well and you're going to have lots more
neural architecture in order to get your
answer which is German so the point here
is that the RNN is acting as an encoder
for the question that is the hidden
States that you get from running the RNN
over the question represent the question
so the encoder is part of a larger
neural system and it's the the hidden
States themselves that you're interested
in because they contain the information
so you could have taken a element-wise
Maxell mean like we showed in the
previous slide to get a single vector
for the question but often you don't do
that often you'll do something else
which uses the hidden States directly so
the general point here is that RNs are
quite powerful as a way to represent a
sequence of texts for further
computation ok last example so going
back to Oran and language models again
they can be used to generate text and
there are lots of different applications
this so for example speech recognition
you will have your input which is the
audio and as a student asked earlier the
we'll be represented in some way and
then maybe you'll do a neural encoding
of that and then you use your RNN
language model to generate the output
which in this case is going to be a
transcription of what the audio
recording is saying so you'll have some
way of conditioning and we're going to
talk more about how this works
in a later lecture but you'll have some
way of conditioning your RNN language
model on the input so you'll use that to
generate your text and in this case the
utterance might be something like what's
the weather question yeah okay so the
question is in speech recognition we
often use word error rate to evaluate
but would you use perplexity to evaluate
I don't actually know much about that
you know Chris what they use in speech
recognition is the answer is you often
use wr4 eval but you might also use
perplexity yeah any other questions
okay so this is an example of a
conditional language model and it's
called a conditional language model
because we have the language model
components but crucially we're
conditioning it on some kind of input so
unlike the fun examples like with the
Harry Potter text where we were just
generating text basically
unconditionally you know we trained it
on the training data and then we just
start it with some kind of random seed
and then it generates unconditionally
this is called a conditional language
model because there's some kind of input
that we need to condition on machine
translation is an example also of the
conditional language model and we're
going to see that in much more detail in
the lecture next week on machine
translation all right are there any more
questions you have a bit of extra time I
think anything the end of your network
you want to run them through by pairs if
you people mix and match like that or
these clips specialize so they really
only accessorize themselves the question
is do you have a combined RN ends with
other types of architectures so I think
the answer is yes you might you know
have you might have other types of
architectures to produce the vectors
that are going to be the input to RN N
or you might use the output of your RN
end and feed that into a different type
of neural networks
any other questions okay so before we
finish I have a note on terminology when
you're reading papers you might find
often this phrase vanilla rnm and when
you see the phrase vanilla RNN that
usually means the Orang ends that isn't
described in this lecture so the reason
why those are called vanilla RN ends is
because there are actually other more
complex kinds of RNN flavors so for
example there's GRU and lsdm and we're
going to learn about both of those next
week and another thing we're going to
learn about next week is that you can
actually get multi there are n ends
which is when you stack multiple RN ends
on top of each other so you're going to
learn about those but we hope that by
the time you reach the end of this
course you're going to be able to read a
research paper and see a phrase like
stacks bi-directional lsdm with residual
connections and self attention and
you'll know exactly what that is that's
just an RNN with all of the toppings all
right thank you that's it for today next
time
[Applause]
next time we're learning about problems
and fancier names